Sarah has just shown you how to implement some methods of the person class. And
here were are back with the car, and ready to implement the remaining methods.
Just to remind you, so far, we've implemented two methods. Add gas and drive.
And when we drive the car, we can see that it has driven. But we have no way of
finding out exactly how much. So let's fix that. We need to add a method that
one can call to find out how many miles the car has driven. Here is the method
header. And here is the implementation. Note this return statement. That
indicates that this method returns a value, namely, the miles driven. Over
here, you didn't have a return statement because the method had return type
void. It didn't return an answer. The method over here has return type double,
and it does return an answer. Any time you implement an accessor, you need to
provide a return statement. Alright, now it's you're turn again. Go ahead and
implement this method. Just put your code in the box.